la réforme de la charte de la langue
française adoptée par le gouvernement
legault entraînera un lot de changements
pour les pme avec nous ce soir pour
expliquer tout cela m britannique hanson
qui est avocate en droit du travail de
l'emploi chez lavery bonsoir madame
personne alors les entreprises de 25 à
49 employés seront dorénavant assujettis
la charte de la langue française
concrètement s'impliquent quoi à court
terme pour les pme là juste pour
préciser premièrement les entreprises
avec de 25 employés et plus vont devoir
maintenant se soumettre au processus de
francisation
donc c'est un processus que auparavant
était vraiment réservé aux entreprises
avec 50 employés et plus ce qui veut
dire qu'ils vont devoir se soumettre à
un processus pour démontrer que le
français est généralisée à tous les
niveaux de leur entreprise donc
évidemment ça va expliquer un peu plus
de travail un peu plus de de
vérification qui est aussi de faire des
inscriptions auprès de l'office et de
démontrer effectivement que dans leur
communication dans la gestion de nos
employés de façon généralisée ils sont
saouls il respecte le fait que là c'est
la langue la langue du travail s'il est
donc une entreprise qui a 25 30 employés
doit avoir toute sa documentation par
exemple disponible en français oui de
façon générale les communications
écrites avec les employés avec leur
personnel normalement ça va être en
français il faut se dire que pour le
processus de francisation
il ya quand même un délai pour respecter
la loi qui est prévu dans le projet de
loi 85 et six mois non qui est quand
même pour l'entrée en vigueur de cette
exigence leur ont pas quand même 2,3 au
clos ce qui va être important surtout
pour des pme c'est de s'assurer que dès
maintenant on fait nos vérifications on
comprend justement à quel point le
français est généralisée de notre
entreprise pour compute effectivement
respecter les obligations
dans les délais prévus par six mois
c'est pour les entreprises de compétence
fédérale qui devront également se
soumettre la doua sort donc pour les
entreprises de compétence fédérale
évidemment c'est une modification qui
fait jaser beaucoup ce qu'il faut dire
également c'est que on s'attend à voir
quand même des contestations judiciaires
ou au moins des débats à ce niveau là le
fédéral en mars dernier a déposé de son
côté un projet de loi le projet de loi c
13 qui vise à modifier la loi c'est la
loi sur les langues officielles et elle
ce projet de loi là prévoit que ça va
être que l'entreprise fédérale va
pouvoir décider de sachets s'assujettir
à la charte de la langue française donc
c'est quand même une certaine dans une
contradiction entre les deux lois donc
ça va être à suivre travail pour les
avocats encore une fois le message
envoyé par québec est quand même très
très clair si vous ne respectez pas la
loi 96 les contraventions seront salés
tout à fait donc ce qu'on voit c'est
quand même des amendes qui sont
augmentés là d'un projet de loi c'est
que pour vous donner un ordre de
grandeur
avant on parlait d'un monde pour une
personne morale dans 13 700 s'est tenue
dans la vie maintenant on va parler
d'amande qui sont quand même de l'ordre
de 3000 à 30000 dollars pour avoir
communiqué dès des faux renseignement on
parle d'un monde qui pourrait passer
entraide email et 250 dollars et
pourrait effectivement puis pour les
administrateurs et les dirigeants
d'entreprises eux ils peuvent être ils
peuvent voir octroyer des amendes qui
sont le double de caisse qui est
normalement prévu pour une personne
physique qui contraignait à la loi un
employeur peut-il exiger la connaissance
de l'anglais ou d'une langue autre que
le français dans une offre d'emploi on
en est où à partir de maintenant avec ce
projet doit donc la réponse courte si
oui mais il faut que l'employeur soit en
mesure de démontrer la nécessité de la
connaissance d'une langue autre que le
français donc ce qui est important c'est
que c'est pas la simple utilité c'est
pas simple le simple fait que ça va
rendre les choses plus difficiles une
fois en poste est vraiment que c'est
nécessaire et cette justification là va
devoir se trouver se retrouver
dorénavant dans l'affichage de postes ok
est ce que si l'employeur réussi à
trouver très exactement que ce poste là
a besoin du bilinguisme ou de connaître
deux langues par exemple l'anglais le
français s qui est ce qu'au nom du
bilinguisme sur ce poste là on pourrait
remercier un employé qui n'est pas
capable de s'exprimer dans deux langues
vous savez si j'avais une cliente qui me
posait cette question là probablement je
leur dirais que ça reste est assez
difficile parce qu'elle est on parle
d'un employé qui est déjà en poste qui
jusqu'à maintenant sambre rencontrer les
exigences de ce poste là donc faudrait
que l'employeur soit à 6
ans mesure vraiment démontré que c'est
une exigence du mystique qui a quelque
chose quelque chose qui a changé il faut
se dire au québec on a quand même des
protections assez importante le pour les
employés
normalement il faut peut-être des fois
démontré une cause juste et suffisante
de fin d'emploi donc ce serait un
fardeau je pense assez élevé là pour un
employeur et on dit que je termine là
dessus parce qu'il nous reste que
quelques secondes les communications
doivent être en français des courriers
dans un anglais l'intérieur d'une
entreprise est ce que c'est accepter
mais ce que je voudrais c'est que si on
est dans une relation l'hiérarchie qu
donc si on est le gestionnaire et on
s'adresse à l'ensemble notre personnel
ou un groupe important de notre
personnel normalement si le sujet de ce
corps et à la touche le lien d'emploi
normalement faudrait que ce document
soit france ok avec toujours deux
nuances bien vite là pour l'instant
britannique olsen merci beaucoup avec
les mercis pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit
oh
[Musique]